foreign
hey you guys time once again for
flickers of fear my little movie review
series got a little bit of an obscure
one for you today now I have to tell you
I honestly have no idea why this
particular 1989 film Cameron's closet or
at least like the title of it and sort
of like the cover image kind of stuck
with me like after all these years
pretty sure that I saw this movie like
on cable probably back in the early
1990s because I think it's definitely
one of those movies that had really
inexpensive broadcast rates and it would
have played like a bunch of times a day
like on one of the pay channels like
back when they didn't have enough
content you know what I mean I can't say
that I remembered anything in particular
about this movie like including whether
I liked it or not but for whatever
reason like whenever I was when I was
recently kind of scrolling through to be
like looking for something to review and
I saw it I kind of felt a little like oh
like a little remembrance a little
Nostalgia thing and uh so I was like
yeah I should probably like re-watch
that maybe I liked it and that's why it
just like stuck out to me and then when
I did re-watch it I have to say I was
even more mystified than I was before
like why this particular movie like
lodged in my brain the way it did I
don't know why my brain works the way it
does please don't ask me I've tried for
50 years to try to figure it out and I
still don't know uh the same thing
incidentally like happened to me with
that 1977 movie Kathy's curse which I
think I reviewed like on this series
like probably like last year or sometime
it was another one that I just like
remembered I was like oh I remember the
cover and I remembered the title and
then I watched it I'm like why the [ __ ]
did I remember that I don't really know
I mean not that Cameron's closet is a
bad movie really it's it's really not
it's not great but it's not bad I mean
it's cheesy and it you know certainly
has its weaknesses but it's really no
worse uh but it's also no more
distinctive than you know any number of
other late 1980s low budget targeted
toward the Home Video Market kind of
movies uh it had some decent Gore in it
and some you know entertaining and like
over the top kills had some pretty solid
acting from some of the people uh and
you know kind of an interesting story uh
had some like big horror stalwarts you
know like working behind the scenes so
you know it wasn't as good as like the
1987 movie the gate for example which it
does kind of like remind me of a little
bit it's not that similar but it kind of
gave me that kind of vibe even though
the gate I feel like was more targeted
toward teenagers or tweens whereas this
one is you would think that but it's
actually not really for kids because
it's like pretty gory I mean this is
just kind of like a fun mostly forgotten
kind of slice of 80s Gorgonzola if you
want to call it that that really barely
anybody ever talks about anymore but you
know because when I was scrolling
through 2B and it just snagged my
eyeballs and I was like why do I
remember this movie uh you know I'm
gonna Buck the trend and I'm gonna
discuss it so you're welcome now when I
mentioned that there was like kind of a
lot of well-known horror people uh
behind the scenes on this thing I
actually was not not kidding so the
screenplay for Cameron's closet was
written by Gary brandner who probably
best known for writing the um the novel
that the movie The Howling was based on
like it's actually like a Trilogy
um but only the first Joe Dante directed
movie was based on the novel like the
other two novels uh howling novels that
Gary Brenner wrote you know they weren't
they didn't correspond to like the
sequels they don't blame him for those
you know what I mean so yeah so you got
the guy that wrote the book The Howling
uh the special effects were actually
done by Carlo rambaldi who won a couple
of oscars he was the guy that designed
E.T you know the Extraterrestrial uh
also worked on special effects for the
1976 version of King Kong uh Alien Close
Encounters of the Third Kind Dune the
David Lynch one and Dario argento's deep
red so you got that uh the director
Armand mastroiani he kind of uh kind of
burst onto the landscape in 1980 with he
knows you're alone and he also did he
did some other movies too but he did
like a lot of really cool like um horror
and Sci-Fi TV series
um you know directed like a lot of
episodes of those like in the like from
like the 80s to the early 2000s like he
worked on Tales from the Dark Side
Friday the 13th the series uh the 90s
reboot of Dark Shadows The Dead Zone the
series that was you know based on the
Stephen King novel which is actually
really good and underrated Anthony
Michael Hall is in it so I recommend
that if you haven't seen it we actually
have it on DVD here at the house and
it's really really good and it's kind of
sad that a lot of people don't talk
about it oh and if all that wasn't
enough
William lustig uh much beloved by horror
nerds for directing both 1980s maniac
and a 1988's Maniac Cop actually like
appears in a cameo in one scene like he
plays a pornographer That Gets Busted by
the cops like in a police station so
even though cameras Cameron's closet I
guess you wouldn't really consider it a
Prestige project or anything like that
but there was a hell of a lot of talent
that went into the making of it so the
movie starts out like kind of along the
same lines as something maybe like fire
starter or maybe Carrie like to a lesser
degree there's a 10 year old boy named
Cameron Lansing who's played by Scott
Curtis who I think went on to become a
musician later on and he has like a very
pronounced like psychokinetic Powers
right his single dad Owen is actually
played by the 50s and 60s heartthrob Tab
Hunter who uh he's been in like a
million movies yeah look at his IMDb
page I actually remember him as the I
know this is gonna sound funny but I
actually remember him from uh Greece too
for being the um the teacher where they
do the reproduction song I don't know
why I remember him from that because
he's been in a [ __ ] ton of other stuff
but I remember him with that so uh so
yeah so the dad Owen
is a scientist and he's basically
studying the kids abilities uh and the
dad has an assistant named Professor Ben
Majors not too far into the story though
uh it's pretty clear that whatever it is
the two men were hoping to achieve they
were trying to like unlock hidden powers
of the mind or something like through
this kid well it's gone drastically awry
though let's call it that uh and it's
implied that perhaps demons or
specifically one demon has become
involved in the situation Owen has
apparently decided that the only way to
solve this problem is to kill his own
son but as he goes to do just that uh
some Force intervenes causing Owen to
accidentally fall onto his own machete
and behead himself which
I admit that I wasn't expecting a scene
like that like that early in the film
like it was like five minutes in I'm
like oh okay we're doing this we're
doing self-beating all right I'm on
board so Cameron then gets sent to live
with his mom his name is Dory and her
abusive Meathead of a boyfriend whose
name is Bob and honestly Bob is like the
most hateable easily the most hateable
character he's supposed to be hateable
like you just cannot wait to see him
like eat some telekinetic [ __ ] because
he's like one of the world's champion
douchebags if they gave out medals for
that [ __ ] he would be right there like
getting the gold so I forgot to mention
though that while all of this kind of
like family drama is going on like over
here over there there's this whole other
subplot happening like and this involves
a cop named Sergeant Sam uh Taliaferro
and he keeps getting his ass reamed by
his superiors for like spacing out and
falling asleep on the job
so during one of these you know sessions
where his you know God damn it what
you're a good cop what's the matter with
you you know one of those kind of
meetings uh he complains that he hasn't
really been getting much sleep because
he's been having all these recurring
nightmares so his boss sends him to see
like this police psychologist
psychiatrist uh who much to say I'm
shock and Chagrin is a woman in a scene
it's like this was 1989 this movie came
out it's like yeah they have they have
female psychiatrists we've had that for
decades and decades now like please get
on board get get with the program but I
just thought that was kind of funny I
don't know if it was just because she
was a woman or just because she was like
an oh like a good looking woman maybe
that's what it was I'm not really sure
so uh so yeah so it's Dr Nora Haley is
the doctor and she's actually played by
Mel Harris so I think is probably best
known for being on uh 30 something and
she like wants to help him but Sam is
very very hostile insisting's like hey
I'm not a nut like all you other all the
other people that come in here I'm like
someone's a little defensive yeah he
comes across like that I mean he's like
where I come from which I don't know
where that is uh people take care of
their own problems even though he
insists he doesn't have any problems so
I'm like all right it's you're one of
those let's see so for a while in the
movie like while I'm watching it like
it's not clear exactly like how
Cameron's story and Sam's story are
related but finally like if you kind of
you know are patient a little bit the
two threads of the story kind of like
intertwine so Cameron you see has
started talking to someone or something
in his closet which should be uh evident
from the name of the movie uh and he
calls it deceptor uh which is also the
name of this weird like pazuzu-esque
kind of statue that he actually got from
his dad but he's been playing with as a
toy like him in the he has like a little
that little muscle man it's not Stretch
Armstrong but it kind of looks like that
except he's it's not like posable or
anything and he like had its them fight
you know like a little boy would do so
one evening after Cameron's you know
just talking to the person in his closet
and just his General existence you know
really uh has aggravated the boyfriend
Bob you know kind of passed the point of
reason this big chuckle [ __ ] like goes
into Cameron's room and starts kind of
like hefting the kid around and like
being abusive and whatnot and this
seemingly causes a demon to pop out the
closet burn out Bob's eyeballs uh which
is nice and fling him out a second story
window Exorcist style I'm gonna say Bob
really catches some air too I mean like
so much so that like when the cops
arrive because he lands on top of a car
so like when the cops get there they
wonder whether the dude fell out of an
airplane which I don't know why that
made me laugh so hard but it did so
anyway it's at this point probably like
half an hour 40 minutes of the movie
something like that uh where Sam and
Cameron meet as Sam is investigating
like Bob's weird ass death now Dr Haley
is also on the scene because she's kind
of trying to assess the trauma that
Cameron might be experiencing after you
know essentially witnessing his mom's
boyfriend get yeeded halfway across the
neighborhood which is like I don't know
why I thought that was him I mean he
went flying it was like hysterical and
it's actually like not a bad effect too
so while she's talking to the kid though
she notices that Cameron appears to use
telekinesis like to keep a vase from
falling off the mantle like a cop walks
by and the vase is like whoa and it's
like off and then it stops like in
midair and it goes back and she sees the
kid like looking over there at it and
she's like
um that kid has psychic powers I mean
she's right but it's like I thought it
was like she's a psychiatrist so you
would think that immediately she
wouldn't jump immediately to that but
you know whatever it's the 80s and
they're just like oh okay cool you have
telekinetic Powers all right so let's
let's drill down on that so as The Story
Goes On like Cameron starts to develop
kind of a rapport like a relationship
with Sam as he's now like completely
without a father figure because you know
he's he's zero for two at this point or
whatever because it's like they're both
dead uh I mean but the two candidates
that he had before were not not really
any great shakes poor kids so you know
what I mean he needs a dad and this
guy's like there uh it's actually
implied
that Cameron was the one that was
sending uh Sam like all those dreams I
guess unconsciously like in somebody
like asking for help uh Sam also starts
to become a little bit you know squishy
a little bit enamored toward Dr Haley uh
unfortunately though things aren't all
rainbows and unicorn farts and whatnot
as the demon which has attached itself
to Cameron I guess
um it's eventually identified as like a
Mayan entity called ziolfo the essence
of evil he's kind of still [ __ ] [ __ ]
up killing pretty much everybody around
the kid in you know creative ways and
even threatening to Chuck Cameron
himself into the blades of a
supernaturally speedy ceiling fan so
there's that uh there's another whole
thing about the demon disguising itself
as like the zombified versions of people
it's already killed in order to like
fool people into doing things like in
order to fool Sam into like killing the
kid and [ __ ] like that I guess that's
why the kids started out calling him
deceptor kind of like a Transformers
kind of reference or you know what I
mean whatever it is the thing about it
though is that I kind of feel like the
mythology of the demon was a little bit
muddled because I was like well wait
it's like I thought they said I mean and
admittedly maybe I wasn't like paying
super close attention but I thought they
said that it's like oh well the demon
can't kill the kid because the demon is
like the
the kid is like the Demon's conduit like
into this Dimension or whatever but then
like the demon does try to kill the kid
and then it tries to like fool Sam and
like other people into killing the kid
too because it was trying to get the dad
to kill the kid at the beginning like
with the macheteer but then it saved it
I don't really know it's like it's it's
very confusing and I'm not really sure
like what the Demon's end game was
exactly but whatever happily it all
works out in the end uh Cameron uses his
awesome powers and Optical effects and
things like that to send zealtho back to
the hell from whence he emerged uh which
it should be noted Cameron was the one
that kind of like summoned him from in
the first place although I mean in the
kid's defense he didn't really do it on
purpose so you know so I mean Cameron's
closet I mean it's not going to win any
awards or anything like that uh but it
was like a pretty brisk entertaining
little flick I mean it's only like 87
minutes long or something like that I
don't know if I'd recommend it to
anybody that didn't see it back in the
day because I feel like you probably
like this one better if you had some of
that kind of like Nostalgia Factor
happening like I don't think it's a good
movie like on its own uh some of the
effects are actually quite good I mean
considering like the team that worked on
this who had worked on like some really
great movies I mean Tab Hunter getting
beheaded like in the beginning that
looks pretty good Bob's eyes getting
scorched out that looked pretty good and
then there was one scene where uh bent
Professor Ben Majors one of the um the
assistant guy he kind of gets
almost like open air microwaved like
dollar store Hot Pocket like you know
what I mean so that looks pretty good on
the other hand though the creature
design on the demon uh was uh let's call
it less than ideal it wasn't great I'm
gonna give the effects team the benefit
of the doubt on that one though and
assume that maybe they ran out of time
and or money because it really looks
kind of like cheesy and I think they
kind of like show it a little too much
so you can see like how cheap it looks
which is kind of unfortunate now this
movie actually did get a very limited
theatrical release believe it or not but
it came out on VHS like the same year
that it had played in theaters so I'm
guessing that was you know the target
market all along and I guess it must
have some kind of at least like small
cult following because it did get like a
DVD release in 2004 but to be honest
it's like really not a movie that gets
mentioned all that much and as far as I
know like nobody's clamoring for like a
special edition Blu-ray steelbook or
anything like that but I mean if you
like movies about demons and telekinetic
kids and you're kind of in the mood for
like some late 80s Nostalgia because
this is a very very 80s movie then you
might dig it like I said it's free it's
on to be you know it's I know that some
people do have some affection for it
because they saw it back in the day I
saw it back in the day too but I didn't
remember anything about it so I don't
know if I had that Nostalgia Factor
going in but it's fine I've seen like
way way worse movies than this
um but you know I've seen way better
ones too so so that's the thing so it's
up to you like if you want to watch an
art if it sounds interesting or if it
sounds cool then check it out it's free
and tell me what you thought about it in
the comments or even if you had ever
even heard of it because I feel like a
lot of people have it so that'll do it
for this flickers of fear I'll see you
guys again on the next one bye